If you guys didn't know, Trump just said
that he's about to disclose UFOs.
>> President Trump announced Thursday
evening that he would be directing
relevant agencies to release files on
aliens and UFOs.
>> Knowing what we know as Bible believing
Christians that this is Satan's final
masquerade, there are millions of people
out there who have no idea what's
coming. All they know is that the
military is telling them that aliens are
real and they're here and they're among
us.
>> Biologics came with some of these
recoveries. Were they I guess human or
non-human biologics?
>> Non-human. And that was the assessment
of people uh with direct knowledge on
the program I talked to.
>> We are going to get 20,000 of these
printed and hopefully we'll get more.
This says top secret UFO disclosure and
Bible prophecy. It's analog so you don't
need the internet or electricity and you
can put it right in somebody's hands and
it's concise and straightforward and
gets right to the point. Printing isn't
cheap but we got a great deal on these
prints from a personal friend of mine in
California. So with your help we can get
20,000 or more of these printed. If you
just click on the donation link below to
help us expose the lies before it's too
late.